et quand on joue à lille histoire comme
ça je ne peux m'empêcher de citer damien
sargue mss 4 plus beau aimer c'est
monter plus haut oui je si oui la
laisser monter si haut par ses montées
si aubin vous allez monter en gamme
parlons des trans au deuxième et à sa
merci les séries juste est-ce que vous
avez déjà eu un coup de foudre vrai bon
bah voilà personne oui jb remet ça quand
j'ai vu fatto absolue ah ouais absolue
obsédant c'est à dire qu'il a fallu il a
fallu que je marche autour yale a eu le
coup de foudre pour vous pas du tout ou
est-ce que alors tiens mais ce que vous
avez vu la personne peut être entendu
pour bachar al assad
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
et
rentré dedans en fait comme je voyais
pas très bien avec ta femme
et oui je leur entrée dont on s'embrasse
et directement away j'étais un vrai un
vrai coup de foudre alors moi j'ai un
dîner pour faire déjeuner professionnel
et j'ai eu un coup de foudre avec la
personne et risquant une comédienne non
on est resté deux ans
alors bien entendu tout le monde admire
de qui c'est mais oui je ne le dirai pas
bien sûr à part si nicolas le dit
lui-même mais moi je ne dirais pas de
qui s'agit avoue la comédienne très
belle un jeu très sec lundi très célèbre
un indice ou regardez moi dans les yeux
j'ai dit dans les yeux
ce qui si peu de temps ça fait beaucoup
de place mais pas sur une radio aux
siens face il ya des règles on aime
beaucoup un bras d'honneur c'est cette
fois c'est la personne le site une
publicité publicité slogan est ce que tu
veux me parler tu veux me dire des
choses oui et ce qui se passe mon bébé
ça sera en ce moment quoi c'est vrai tu
es content d'être avec nous quand même
très content est-ce qu'on est ton rayon
de soleil de la journée
c'est plus que ça non c'est vrai quand
même mais c'est bon c'est bon
si ce conte et oriente soleil de la
tâche on est aussi stylée bah oui non
c'est vrai ta ble ment
aujourd'hui oui tu as 2 tab 2 gb2 exact
alors qu un moment tu sais laurent et
moi on se met d'accord sur la commenter
car la garde garde de l'enfant c'est
laurent wauquiez le regard de laurent
bravo entre les records exactement
ok well as non mais voilà est ce que tu
es heureux discute et j'ai eu un coup de
foudre deux fois non alors deux fois
inquiétez pas partager et à partager
quand c'est pas partager c'est terrible
ah bah ouais si je suis là voir un coup
de foudre pour quelqu'un parce que le
foot c'est quoi on le voit que je suis
belge donc je le vois et on pense à lui
tout le temps dans tout le temps fait
des films en serait là ensemble dînent
ensemble on lire à la plage ensemble et
puis rien on n'a rien merci comme moi
quand je vois une près il est comme ça
qu on sait qu'à ça on y pense qu'a ta
groupe e journée et me vois pas aller
les vilaines et ben moi et mon compagnon
actuel quoi baver coup d'oeil pour
bateaux rendez vous professionnel ah
ouais et effectivement quand je le vois
je me dis il a tout pour lui ce type non
à oui je les trouvais immédiatement beau
charismatique et eau
[Rires]
musée
j'ai immédiatement freiné parce que tout
de suite regardé ses mains et j'ai vu
qu'il avait une bague au doigt il était
marié et en favorite ayant une bague non
invasif et comme les pigeons il met une
bague au doigt s'accomplit en fait le
gars le gala n'est que là mais c'était
de en plastique blanches comme ça c'est
triste et pigeons dans une autre vie
voilà il a gardé la gueule à donges est
scruté ça ah ouais mais après j'ai vu
qu'il est parfois ils la mettaient
parfois l'était pas et puis très vite
j'ai su qu'il était célibataire et donc
voilà j'ai alors vous est ce que vous
avez eu un coup de foudre pour roger oui
c'est vrai c'était on n'est pas dedans
[Rires]
donc oui donc c'était je comptais
forcément en discothèque et traitent
tous les week-ends j'y allais la
discothèque pour le voir oui ouais et
donc du coup je ne l'entendais que sous
le prisme de quand on crie dans les
oreilles et puis avec la nuit comme ça
et est donc la première fois au bout de
un mois que je les ai vus en vrai à la
lumière du jour et sans la musique ça
m'a fait très bizarre c'était pareil que
faire pour a
c'est donc pendant dix semaines
elle était avec roger déjà claude ah
ouais les gars je m'appelle delphine
tuba de la terrine ont fait pas de ça la
boîte d'un médecin est d'ailleurs toute
la soirée était comme un saint ben ouais
je suis une ancienne miss trop ce qu'est
ce que tu aimes pas faire trop de
dépenses
et puis qu'est ce qui est beau c'est un
truc de ouf pour l'embrasser en tout cas
ruggieri on embrasse on embrasse voilà
on l'a projet on tombera t il et pas
plus à l'est c'est marius dans les bons
délais
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
j'adore j'adore et alors jardim a dit
vous
alors moi daniel montagne est rigolo
ouais j'ai mis un coup de se séparer si
pour coder pas non mais j'étais droit au
salon du livre et gérer dont les allées
comme une âme en peine et je les villes
étaient en train dédicacer son ouvrage
et j'ai trouvé tout de suite
la charismatique brillant d'un petit peu
parlé et je me suis dit que c'était
l'homme de ma vie c'est houphouet salon
le livre ça mais j'ai ramé c'est un
raisonnement préférer les salons du
livre
je vais tous les ans vous allez porte de
versailles je passe devant moi j'ai un
couteau pour delphine mais amicale bien
sûr ça c'est vraiment moi c'est parce
qu'on y joue un coup de foudre amical
pour vider un coup de coude avec roger
sirotant son fouet alors bal avec roger
roger dans la nature fera son travail
je trouve que quand même il en parle
beaucoup de daffy duck ou verre d'amitié
que l'avionneur moi je pense que l'huile
et ou de delphine et que des visas et
dit attendre papy par sam hamad
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
j'avais vraiment un coup de foudre à
part pour de l'oseille
[Rires]
leur confinement a pas pour une garce de
ça s'emballe alors à barr delphine dont
la paraffine j'observe mais c'est vrai
qu'il n'est pas bien et fébrile en fin
mais j'ai mis les toulonnais des non non
c'est pas ça
réveillez pas fébrile pour ça c'est quoi
il fait beau parce qu'il aurait acheté
en soit ce que vous avez déjà eu un coup
de foudre
alors une fois on était un pique nique
je n'ai vu arriver au loin avec son
chapeau pour vous dire j'ai en pique
nique il a vachement mais si j'ai encore
cette semaine dans mes textes tellement
ça m'a marqué on est resté deux ans
enfants c'est la seule personne à qui je
tombais amoureuse ce qui est une
matheuse ce qui ma rue st non il est
énorme et il m'a quitté
moi je pensais que c'était l'homme de ma
vie aussi mais lui non ouais ouais c'est
vous l'avez rencontré un pique nique un
pique nique mois d'août avec un chapeau
il marche à peine écouté je peux pas
terminer cette séquence sur celle là
désastre un visage vous croyez coup de
foudre mélodie vous dire moi je crois
car un seul coup de foudre
ouais ces écoutes foot professionnel
c'est à dire je peux très vite savoir
quelqu'un avec qui je suis bien
m'entendre dans le travail ou quelqu'un
qui l'a vite dégagé qu'est ce qui vous
fait le truc où vous vous dites lui oui
lui non ils n'ont louis luneau le tarif
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]